i
thought this was such an interesting
film because it feels like this big
concept story but it's told in such a
personal way
so when you read the script what did you
make of the world that it creates did
you visually see it right away or did
you have a lot of questions
i actually feel like i saw it um
basically
just as it just as it appears in the
film i i have to say i think it is
pretty true to
what i kind of imagined edson i think
did a good job of sort of
providing a visual world in the script
that he wrote uh
and sort of even the contrast of this
like
small house it felt sort of like womb
like in comparison to the expanse of the
desert
uh get matched up pretty well to what i
had
pictured yeah i would echo that it
really
what what was on the script and on the
page
really was translated pretty directly to
screen
um and the script didn't change very
much
we changed a little bit of language to
make it a lot more
nuanced for the actor playing like
we got a chance to like cut lines and
things like that but
if anything edson did more cutting back
on the script than he did really adding
to it because it was already so
full and i think what we made was pretty
much what was always
on paper it feels like a huge
responsibility to be someone who
determines
which individuals are most suitable for
the journey of life
so winston up until this moment how has
will
felt about that i think will
is in a place of deep confusion and
it is a huge conflict for him
being a person who's lived before who
to some degree feels like he was
defeated by life
to the point where he took his own life
and now has to be the person
who is deciding who gets to be born and
with a clear understanding that life can
be hard and life can be
traumatic can be painful but he's still
in a space of
trying to decide and help you know
guide these spirits to essentially what
might be you know
one of their final destinations and
giving this present to all the others
it's just something that's really
special so i think
for will i i will i don't think really
wants to be there but the way he goes
through
his life and his world is one of trying
to have as much control as he can
because that's the only thing that seems
like reality that he can actually
he can actually discern like even him
waking up in that space
i must and i i kind of imagined was
incredibly traumatic
it seems so sad and lonely and empty to
watch
life unfold on a series of old tv sets
so zassie what do you think it is that
makes emma different what do you think
it is about her that
makes will start to look at things
differently
emma just sort of functions a lot in the
present
and remaining present and uh
really just seeing things as they are
right in front of her whether they're
good or bad and i think will kind of
being
sort of in the space of the doldrums of
um you know day-to-day existence
i think that emma kind of
awakens uh sort of interest again in
um but these things that you're doing
every day are special
and i think that her kind of child
child-like wonder around it all uh
is infectious um to will
and allows him to review
what he's been taking for granted and
then even to
choose to review what his pain is and
what his grief is versus kind of just
like
compartmentalizing it and putting it
away i think she challenges it and
and says i see this here too like what
is it
uh and makes him kind of face it
and uh yeah i think she's a very unique
she's very unique character i mean all
all of them have this but the the
uniqueness in not having a backstory not
having a background and really just
engaging in
what's right there and i think emma
particularly
um is very just moment by moment
oriented not the future
and not the past because i think some of
the other spirits have a bit more
um concern about the future and what's
going to happen with them
there's something so incredibly
beautiful and
and sad about that sequence at the end
where will
is giving his monologue and and the two
of them are having these
moments and they're screaming with each
other what
got you into that moment to really live
in it and embrace
and feel all of it was part of what
helped you guys having each other
there you know it's very interesting
we didn't rehearse that that scene at
all between the two of us i know winston
you were working on
the monologue you and edson were doing
stuff together but
um i kind of just went in
and just listened and i remember you
know during the whole shoot as will
winston you had kind of like a um
you know your character was kind of
guarded or trying to protect himself and
i remember that day he came in and
you're like i'm just ready to give
and it was really cool to um
to see will give
and um and i wanted and i
i was very moved by it and
i was surprised at how just kind of
being there and then with the desert
being so wide open it was such a
different feeling uh
it felt very cathartic versus this kind
of small
space that we had been living in up
until that moment um
those were like the last days of
shooting when we did that and so
there was a you know i think it was a
mix of
of preparing a shift in how we were
working
and then uh also just this change in
space was it the same way for you
winston i mean was that something that
really just felt like a moment to have
of course you know i always say that the
scene didn't really come together until
the final
scene partner showed up and that was the
salt assault flats the desert
and the desert itself informed
us on what the monologue meant
and how we can exist in that moment
because we were just out there in the
open and
there was a lot of beautiful energy like
a lot of beautiful energy of land and
environment there
and when you're speaking about
resources and natural factors and being
in touch with the earth and being in
touch with
all things around you there's no better
stage
and no better you know scene partner
than than the landscape
and it really became something
incredibly special
and then that combined with like zasey
said
we built towards that moment so we had
nothing but a lot of trust as performers
and the
kind of agape love that the two of them
created for each other um
emma and will kind of got to be
center stage at that moment where she
finally got to play with him
he finally got to play again
and it was really you know it became
something that just was
really special well winston we we all
know that
the black panther sequel is filming but
i'm curious for you
after making the first movie and the
success of that and then the loss of
chadwick was it emotional
to read that script yeah it was very
emotional to read the script
it was emotional to pack to go back to
set
um but you know
we're all a bit of a family now
and you know we grief together and we're
making something really special
let's see for you what can you say to
tease
season two of invincible i have no
i don't know what's gonna happen you
probably know more than i do
i already all i know is that i'm anxious
yeah no um honestly i have nothing
to say i don't know we'll see
thank you for talking to me i i loved
this i thought it was so beautiful so
thank you
thank you so much christina